so let me first tell you what a braid is
imagine that you have like two wooden
planks and then there are some strings
attached in a neat row to the first
wooden plank and then they are all
tangled up but then when they arrive to
the top they are again in a neat
straight line where they started so like
one goes to one two goes to two yes so
that's called a pure braid and when we
talk about pure braids today it doesn't
hugely matter you can also consider ones
that that crisscross an end that's
somewhere else but let me try to draw
and that actually goes back to where it
started from
it goes from bottom to the top in
between you have some tangled mess so
when you have some big tangled mess
what's your what's the first question
that comes to mind
how would you untangle it how would you
untangle it or can you even untangle it
so sometimes you have a big tangled mess
and it's entirely possible to untangle
it what does it mean to untangle it it
means to make it into this braid this is
like the non brain so how do you
untangle something so imagine that the
strands are say made of rubber they are
stretchy you can move them around as
much as you want you can stretch as much
as you want but you cannot cut them once
you cut them the game is ruined so the
question is if you see a tangled mess
like this can you make it into a and
untangle this has some practical
applications for example if you made
this I do a year ago I had long hair and
when you braid long hair oh maybe I can
show you on just this little bit so the
standard thing you do is you divide it
into three parts this will make me look
rather silly and then you do this braid
one goes over it the middle one and then
the other goes over but became the
middle one and you just continue doing
this until you reach the end of your
hair and then you put an elastic on it
now it's not two wooden planks but at
the top it's attached to your head and
at the bottom it's fastened
an elastic so the top and bottom are
kind of fixed the same as in the picture
that I just showed you and the good
thing about that parade is that it
cannot be untangled because if it could
be untangled then as you move your head
around it probably would become
untangled and the one that I just drew
probably cannot be untangled for example
if you look at just the first and the
last string you can see that those are
like this they they are kind of wrapped
around each other in a way that you
can't imagine untangling so why is it
that some rates cannot be undone when
you move the strands around move the
strings around what's the problem that
you might run into it's the two strands
catch on each other and you can't move
them past each other without breaking
them so that's the main reason that some
braids cannot be undone if the strands
would just go through each other
magically it ghosts then any braids
could be undone this is in
three-dimensional space that we all know
very well because we live in it I'm
claiming that if you think of braids in
four dimensional space then they become
completely uninteresting the main reason
is that if you have two strands in four
dimensional space they can basically go
through each other like ghosts so why is
that let me try to give you an analogy
first so there's a little ant that lives
in the plane so this ant is
two-dimensional all it ever knew was
this two-dimensional plane that it lives
in and this two-dimensional plane has a
wall the wall is one dimensional it's
just a line in the plane so this little
ant can't go through the wall and we'll
never know what's on the other side of
the wall it just hits a red line it just
hits a red line and it can't go through
it what happens if one day a miracle
happens and all of a sudden the world of
this end becomes 3-dimensional so all of
a sudden there's height that day the end
could just go up to the line and say
wait but this line has no height at all
so I can just jump over it and discover
the
their side so that's how if you add a
dimension things that were uncrossable
before are suddenly crossable because
you can use the extra dimension to cross
them is that assuming that when we kick
up to the fourth dimension our hair
doesn't take on an extra dimension with
it exactly yes
exactly so this wall that the end that
that has kept the end on one side of its
plane for its entire life when you add
it an extra dimension the wall didn't
suddenly become infinitely high in
two-dimensional so that's a very good
point so let me try to show you why this
end picture is relevant to the braids
and the fourth dimension so you have a
braid in three dimensions and you can't
untangle it because somewhere you have
two strands that you want to move past
each other and you can so this is one
strand and behind it there's another
strand and you want to move it past what
you can't because it gets stuck on this
strand that's in front of it yeah so
what you want to do is to move this but
it's not working
imagine the plane in which this front
strand lives and this strand behind that
you're trying to move past will only
intersect that plane in one point right
so that point will basically be the end
so if you're just thinking of the
picture that you can see in this one
plane then you have the end which is
where the strand behind intersects the
plane and you have this other strand
which lives in the plane and that's the
wall and then when I try to move this
strand behind and get stuck on this
trend that's basically the end running
up against the wall that becomes the
hitting point of the two strands that
becomes the hitting point but if I add
an extra dimension now this is hard to
imagine because I mean the the braid is
already in three-dimensional space so
then I have an extra fourth dimension
you can imagine that extra fourth
dimension by imagining that this
playing all of a sudden becomes a
three-dimensional space okay so if I add
an extra dimension to the whole picture
then there will be an extra dimension
added to this plane so in this new space
the bottom braid can simply jump over
the other strand in the extra dimension
so not in the three dimensions that it
lived in before but when you add the
extra dimension it can jump over could
you still braid your hair if you were a
four dimensional being and your hair
have a new property that still made
upgradable well it depends so if I
stayed the same but I was placed in four
dimensions then no for the reason that I
just told you because each strand of my
hair is basically one dimensional your D
and I would probably all fall apart as
well but if when I was placed in four
dimensions I myself became four
dimensional and my strands of hair
became two-dimensional then I could so I
said braids in four dimensions aren't
interesting and now I will show you why
they are
the key is that it's not enough to braid
strings I just showed you that if you're
braiding strings that can always be
undone in the fourth dimension so I have
to show you what to braid instead you
can braid something besides strings to
show you that first I like to show you a
different way to see just regular braids
in three dimensions and since we were
talking about ends so you have some ends
and I'm making a movie in which the ends
start out in a neat straight line and
then they crawl around and eventually
they get back to the neat straight line
I will film them doing this and then
there will be a whole bunch of frames I
could imagine just stacking the frames
in the first frame I have the four ends
in a straight line and then in the
second frame they will have moved
slightly in the third frame they will
have moved again and then so on and so
forth until I get to the last frame in
which they are again in a straight line
and in between if I trace all the ways
that they had moved what we got there is
a braid okay so if I make a movie of
ants crawling on a plane then that's the
same as having a braid in 3d just by
stacking all the movie frames on top of
each other so what does my previous
statement mean in this context so my
previous statement is that braids in
four dimensions are uninteresting what
would be braids in four dimensions well
it would be like flies flying around in
three-dimensional space and then I make
a movie of the flies flying around and I
stack them on top of each other so the
fourth dimension is the time and the
frames of the movie each frame is a
three-dimensional thing because they are
flying in space so what I get is graded
strings and four dimensions so that is
still uninteresting to a mathematician
for the same reason why it's
uninteresting to you because it wouldn't
fold your hand it wouldn't hold your
hair together it can always be undone so
there's no very
interesting analysis that can be done
the only point I want to get out of it
is that you can think of this
uninteresting object as a movie about
Flash and now I can tell you what the
interesting object is instead of making
a movie about flies you could make a
movie about other things moving around
in three-dimensional space the one that
I actually think about in my research is
rings flying around in three-dimensional
space so if you have some rings they
start out in a straight line and then
they can fly around in three-dimensional
space and eventually get back to the
same position if I make a movie about
this and take all these
three-dimensional movies frames and
stack them on top of each other in four
dimensions I get something like a braid
so your breathing tubes as opposed to
rings tubes are two-dimensional so
you're braiding two-dimensional things
in four-dimensional space so wire rings
more interesting than flies I have some
slightly mangled rings here so if they
just fly around not interacting ever
they are exactly like flies on the air
boring but since they are rings they
have a hole inside something they can do
is fly right through each other and
flying through each other that's
fundamentally different from just being
flies and that's what makes these
braided tubes something interesting as
opposed to just braided strings which in
four dimensions are uninteresting so
they are allowed to expand and and get
smaller and bigger as they need to
further purpose of flying through each
other as they fly through each other
they create the analogous kind of
tangled mess kind of things that you can
move past each other right within a
braid yeah it's a tube going through
another tube which would be impossible
in three dimensions for a tube to go
through another tube without
intersecting it but in four dimensions
it's possible and it catches the same
way that strings would catch on each
other in three dimensions can I only go
completely
we inside each other or can they overlap
like no they can't intersect so they are
still you know there you can think of
them as physical objects physical object
they are not phantom rings the material
doesn't go through each other it's just
the Rings flying through the hole inside
the other ring this you can generalize
to any dimensions so in three dimensions
you can braid one-dimensional string
with a one-dimensional string one
dimensions with one dimensions one plus
one equals two which is three minus one
in four dimensions you can braid a
one-dimensional with a two-dimensional
so that's the fly when you take the
trajectory in time that is the ring when
you take the trajectory in time that's
three and three equals four minus one
you can also braid a two-dimensional
with a two-dimensional which is four
which is bigger than four minus one and
similarly in five dimensions you
couldn't breathe a one-dimensional with
a one-dimensional or a one-dimensional
with a two-dimensional but you could you
could do two with two or three with
three as long as dimensions of your two
strings add up to at least the dimension
of the containing space minus one then
you can break them together but in my
research I mostly think about one in two
dimensional things braided or tangled in
four dimensional space or the simplest
thing of one dimensional things braided
or tangled in three-dimensional space
and the relationships between them
so my favorite way of visualizing it is
is to think of it in terms of movies in
three dimensions and that is actually a
little bit restrictive because visualize
the fourth dimension is time and time
only moves forward